en el vídeo pasado estuvimos hablando
acerca del espacio nulo y de hecho
construimos bastante teoría acerca del
espacio pero en este vídeo que hacer un
ejercicio específico para encontrar el
espacio nulo de esta matriz
es decir voy a buscar todos los vectores
de la siguiente manera déjame poner aquí
a mi vector x que va a ser mi vector
cuyas componentes son am x1 y x2 x 3 y x
4 este vector x voy a decir que está en
el espacio un nulo de esta matriz am se
cumple que esta matriz a por este vector
x es el vector 0 que por cierto cuántos
componentes debería de tener mi vector
resultante pues ya es una matriz de tres
por cuatro tenemos tres filas y cuatro
columnas y por otro lado del vector x
que es de 4 x 1 tengo cuatro filas por
una columna déjenme ponerlo aquí x es un
vector de 4 por 1 existe en r 4 entonces
mi vector resultante debe tener 3 por 13
filas por una columna es un vector que
existe en la red
justo esto fue lo que vimos en la
primera vez que hablamos acerca de la
multiplicación de una matriz por un
vector así que entonces si yo tengo a
esta matriz a y lo multiplicó por mi
vector x y yo quiero que este vector x
este es un espacio nulo entonces me
tienen que dar el resultado el vector 0
pero el vector 0 con tres componentes el
que existe en r3 y bueno déjame
escribirlo aquí yo lo que voy a buscar
en este vídeo es el espacio nulo de la
matriz a y lo definir la vez pasada como
todos los vectores x en r 4 que cumplen
los siguientes x existen r 4 porque
tenemos 4 componentes y van a cumplir
que la matriz ha multiplicado
precisamente por este vector me tiene
que dar el vector 0
que multiplica al vector x es igual al
vector 0 y yo lo que voy a buscar es
todo estos vectores x todos ellos el
universo de estos vectores x que cumplan
esta propiedad pero bueno a ver primero
voy a hacer la multiplicación de esta
matriz por este vector y que me va a
quedar pues me queda 1 por x 1 1 por x 1
es x 1 + 1 por x 2 es x 2 + 1 por x 3
que es x 3 y después 1 por x 4 que es x
4 x 1 + x2 más extremos x 4 y esto tiene
que ser igual a la primer componente de
este vector resultante es decir tiene
que ser igual a cero ahora vamos con el
producto punto del segundo vector fila
con el vector xy tiene que ser igual a
cero me queda que x 1 más 2 veces x 2
más 3 veces x 3 más 4 veces x 4 más 4
veces x 4 esto tiene que ser igual a
otra vez al escalar 0 tiene que ser
igual a 0 a este 0 que tengo aquí y por
último otra vez voy a tomar el producto
punto de este último vector fila por el
vector xy tiene que ser igual a cero
cuatro veces este cuatro veces x1 déjame
ponerlo aquí 4 veces x 13 veces x 2 lo
único que estamos calculando el producto
punto de esto se me queda cuatro veces x
13 veces x 2 + 2 veces x 3 + x 4 + x 4
esto tiene que ser igual también al
vector ser desempeñando aquí tiene que
ser igual al vector 0 ahora lo primero
que quiero que te des cuenta es que
estamos buscando a todos los componentes
x 1 x 2 x 3 x 4 que cumplan estas tres
ecuaciones sin embargo tengo un sistema
de ecuaciones con cuatro incógnitas y
tres ecuaciones y bueno entonces para
resolver esto podemos escribir estas
mismas ecuaciones como una matriz
aumentada y después poner esta matriz en
su forma escalonada y así saber qué
soluciones tienen estas ecuaciones y
encontrar así mi espacio nulo así que
vamos a escribir esta matriz aumentada
primero y me queda 11 4 123 después 1 2
3 después de 13 2 1 3 2 y para finalizar
1 4 1
41 ya esto le vamos a aumentar el vector
000 perfecto ahora lo que quiero que te
des cuenta es lo que está pasando fíjate
bien tenemos esta matriz multiplicando
este vector igual del vector 0 y
entonces llegamos a este sistema de
ecuaciones y para resolver este sistema
de ecuaciones vamos a trabajar con esta
matriz aumentada que es lo que quiero
que te des cuenta es que esta matriz
aumentada es la matriz am es de aquí es
la matriz am y es lo que está al lado lo
que estamos aumentando es el vector 0
ahora bien para encontrar este sistema
de ecuaciones lo que me doy cuenta es
que tengo que escalonar esta matriz pero
pase lo que pase aquí siempre me va a
quedar 0 en el lado derecho siempre me
va a quedar 0 porque 0 por lo que sea 0
+ 0 pues me da 0 - 0 me da 0 entonces
realmente lo que sebas este problema es
a escalonar la matriz a sí nosotros
escalona mos la matriz a entonces vamos
a encontrar la solución de este problema
pero déjame hacerlo para que te des
cuenta bien a qué me estoy refiriendo lo
primero que voy a hacer es dejar el
primer renglón tal cual igualito 111
otro 1 y aquí un 0 y después acá abajo
lo que voy a hacer
reemplazar el renglón 2 con el renglón 2
- el renglón 1 el renglón 2012 el
renglón 1 es decir me voy a tomar 1 - 1
lo cual me da 0
2 - 1 lo cual me da 13 menos 1 lo cual
me da 2 y 4 menos uno lo cual me da 3 y
0 - 0 pero 0 -0 es 0 fíjate cómo va la
idea de lo que estaba diciendo aquí del
lado derecho van a quedar puros ceros y
el renglón número 3 lo que voy a hacer
es tomarme cuatro veces y el renglón
número uno y restando a este renglón
número tres es decir 4 por 14 menos 40 4
por 14 menos 3 14 por 14 menos 22 y
después 4 por 14 menos 13 y 4 por 0 000
si te das cuenta mi parte derecha está
llena de puros ceros y bueno siguiente
paso lo que quiero hacer es escalonar
esta matriz de cómo voy a hacer es
tomarme este y este renglón así que
déjenme ponerme en donde él me dio
exactamente igual y me queda 0 1
3 1 2 3 1 2 3 y después un 0 y ahora voy
a trabajar con el renglón 1 y con el
renglón 3 y ahora lo que voy a hacer es
reemplazar este primer renglón como el
renglón 1 - el renglón 2 en lugar del
región 1 voy a escribir el renglón 1 -
el renglón 2 me queda este menos este 11
011 - 10 12 me da menos 1 y 1 menos tres
me da menos 3 y 0 - 0 0 y bueno déjame
regresar también en este tercer renglón
como el segundo renglón menos el tercer
renglón y que me va a quedar pues 0 - 0
es 0 1 1 es cero
2 - 2 0 también 3 menos 30 también y 0 -
0 0 y creo que ya estás viendo a dónde
vamos porque ahora este sistema de
ecuaciones se acaba de reducir a lo
siguiente tenemos una ecuación menos me
va a quedar que este mismo un sistema de
ecuaciones es análogo a poner lo
siguiente una vez x 1 entonces una vez x
1 déjenme cambiar de color este de aquí
es x 1 después 0 veces x 2
- una vez x 3 después menos x 4 y esto
es igual a 0
ojo como tengo 10 veces x2 pues entonces
no pongo x2 y este segundo renglón se va
a traducir en lo siguiente en una vez x
2 + 2 veces x 3 + 3 veces x 4 esto es
exactamente igual a 0 y esta última
ecuación después ya es trivial no tiene
nada que ver es innecesario ponerla y
fíjate bien de esta ecuación que tenemos
aquí de nuestra primera ecuación voy a
despejar a x 1 y x 1 a quien es igual x
es igual a x 3 lo estoy pasando del otro
lado de la ecuación más más 2 veces x 4
ojo aquí cometió un error aquí va un 2
es este 2 de aquí menos 2 veces x 4
igual a cero entonces yo lo paso del
otro lado de la ecuación me queda que x
1 es igual x 3 + 2 veces x 4 esto es la
primera actuación y la segunda ecuación
qué pasa si yo despejó a x2 pues me va a
quedar que x 2 es igual a menos 2 veces
x 3
voy a pasar los otros dos términos del
otro lado de la ecuación con signo
contrario menos 2 veces x 3 menos 3
veces x 2 y entonces ya que tengo estas
dos ecuaciones
qué voy a hacer pues fíjate muy bien las
voy a escribir como vectores el vector
inicial nuestro vector x cuyas
componentes serán x 1 x 2 x 3 x 4 ahora
lo puedo escribir de la siguiente manera
este vector que es nuestro vector que
estoy buscando es exactamente lo mismo
que x 3 que multiplica a 1 + x 4 que
multiplica a dos porque date cuenta que
x1 es exactamente igual que x 3 más 2
veces x 4 stojic reemplazando x 1 en
términos de x 3 y x 4 una vez x 3 + 2
veces x 4 todo esto me lo estoy tomando
de esta ecuación que acabamos de
construir de esta ecuación de aquí
arriba y lo único que estoy haciendo
reemplazando a x1 después x os lo voy a
reemplazar por esto que tengo aquí por
menos 2 veces x 3 menos 3 veces x 4 4
aquí hay un error este 2 es un 4 este de
aquí es x 4 fíjate tengo x 2 más 2 veces
x 3 más 3 veces x 4 igual a 0 y entonces
si despejó x 2 me queda que x 2 es igual
a menos 2 x 3 menos 3 x 4
ando bastante concentrado en el problema
y se me están yendo estos errores muy
graves pero ya los corregir ya tengo
aquí a todos mis errores limpios de
nuevo y entonces ahora si vamos bien x 3
lo puedo ver como una vez que es 30
veces x 4 x 4 pues lo puedo ver como 0
veces x 3 más una vez
x 4 es decir que este vector x que
existe en r 4 que por cierto lo que
buscábamos es que este vector cumpliera
la ecuación homogénea lineal asociada
que era x de igual a 0
ahora lo puedo ver como una combinación
lineal de estos dos vectores porque x 3
x 4 existen en los reales pueden ser
cualquier valor x 3 estos números reales
y x 4 también es un número de los reales
por lo tanto al final estoy descubriendo
que este efector x que era bastante
importante para encontrar un espacio
nulo de la matriz am estaba disfrazado
como una combinación lineal de estos dos
vectores que acabo de encontrar
cualquier combinación lineal que me tome
estos dos vectores va a cumplir mi
ecuación lineal a homogénea asociada y
por lo tanto mi espacio nulo
esta matriz am es exactamente igual a
todas las combinaciones lineales de
estos dos vectores pero como escribir
eso como el espacio vectorial generado
por estos dos vectores todas las
combinaciones lineales de estos dos
vectores es el espacio vectorial
generado por nuestro vector
1 - 2 1 0 y el vector
2 - 3 0 y 1 2 3 0 y 1 pero antes de que
te vayas quiero que analicemos una cosa
bastante interesante bastante importante
fíjate bien nosotros tomamos una matriz
am y entonces trabajamos con este
sistema de ecuaciones después hicimos
una matriz aumentada y al final llegamos
en la forma escalonada de la matriz a
que era justo esta de aquí esta es la
forma escalonada de la matriz a déjame
ponerlo aquí la forma escalonada de la
matriz am y ahora que ya tenía la forma
escalonada de la matriz a lo que hice
fue multiplicada por el vector x y
buscar las soluciones que fueran iguales
a 0 es decir ya que tuve la forma
escalonada de la matriz a la multiplique
por el vector x y lo hice igual
20 que era exactamente esta misma parte
que tenemos aquí ahora bien esta x es mi
misma x inicial que resuelve este
problema que tenemos aquí por lo tanto
lo que estábamos buscando con esta x era
el espacio nudos de la matriz am pero en
esta forma se ve claramente que la x
también es el espacio nulo de la forma
escalonada de la matriz a esta x cumple
esta ecuación igual al vector 0 esto
quiere decir que es el espacio nulo de
la forma escalonada de la matriz a pero
esta misma x resolvía esta ecuación que
tenemos aquí abajo y de hecho esta x que
buscábamos era nuestro famoso espacio
nulo de la matriz av
por lo tanto estoy diciendo que el
espacio nulo de la matriz am es
exactamente igual al espacio nulo de la
forma escalonada de la matriz a y esto
que estoy diciendo es bastante
importante porque entonces ya que
tenemos una matriz am lo que tenemos que
hacer es buscar la forma escalonada de
esta matriz am y después buscar el
espacio nudo de la forma escalonada de
la matriz a lo cual parece ser mucho más
sencillo que inicialmente buscar
de la matriz y una vez que ya tenemos la
forma escalonada de la matriz a lo
multiplicamos por el vector x y
encontramos estas ecuaciones las cuales
serán mucho más fácil de trabajar para
que así nos pudieran dar tarde o
temprano nuestro resultado que en este
caso fue el espacio vectorial generado
por estos dos vectores bueno de
cualquier manera espero que todo esto
que te estoy contando te sea bastante
útil de aquí en un futuro